good evening everybody this is a meeting
of the planning and development
management Committee of Trafford Council
my name is councilor Ben Hartley I'm the
chair of the committee on my immediate
writers councilor Barry Wayne Stanley
the vice chair on our uh left and right
offices from the council from the
planning team highways team and the
legal team uh and then down the tables
on the left and the right are members of
the committee who are all elected local
councilors
uh just to note the meeting is being
live streamed on the council's uh
YouTube channel
um and we will move on to uh item number
one which is attendances and apologies
for any absence
I know we've had apologies from uh
councilor Walsh and councilor O'Brien is
a substitute for counselor Walsh and
we've had apologies from councilor
Shirley Proctor and councilor Kevin
Proctor is here in her place and we've
also had apologies from councilors
chalking and uh Morgan but I don't
believe there is a substitute for
either of those two members
everybody else is here I think item
number two is Declarations of Interest
so this is members to give notice of any
personal or prejudicial interest and the
nature of that interest relating to any
item on the agenda in accordance with
the adopted code of conduct are there
any members looking to make Declarations
of interest to cancel the minis
[Music]
um
[Music]
the point set something out so one of
the items um item 106 507 is data is
being liberal Democrats headquarters it
isn't and it hasn't been for over a year
uh the land that was sold it was owned
by the local liberal Democrat Party and
it's not anymore and it hasn't been for
some time so it shouldn't be labeled as
that anyway but
um given that I'm extremely familiar
with the land I will I'll take myself
out of the room for it but I mean I
don't have any financial interest or you
know my party has no financial interest
either with it um at all because we
don't own it or anything anymore thank
you
okay thank you counselor Menace any
other members looking to declare
interests yeah councilor Hassan yeah
thank you uh because I have been already
been involved because the constituents
have approached me two three times and I
don't think it is appropriate for me to
see the second application no
it's a conflict of my interest thank you
thank you Council has answer you'll be
leaving us for the second application
um grateful any other members looking to
declare any interests no okay we'll move
on to item number three which is the
minutes of the last meeting so it's to
receive and if so determined to prove
there's a correct record the minutes of
the meetings held on the uh 8th
September and the 13th September and
we're showing the papers so the 8th
September was
um the uh adjournment uh due to the
passing of how much did a queen
and then we have the minutes of the the
meeting that went ahead on the 13th
September uh any members able to move
councilor wins down this happened to
move those minutes
uh and go to the wealth and up at a
second so those are approved as uh the
minutes of those two meetings thank you
item number four is questions from
members of the public so this is a
maximum of 15 minutes on the agenda will
be allocated to public questions
submitted in writing to democratic
Services by 4 pm on the Working Day
prior to the meeting questions must be
within the remake of the committee it'll
be relevant to items appearing on agenda
and will be submitted in the order in
which they're received but I understand
we haven't had any questions from
members of the public for this meeting
I'll move on then to item number five
the additional information report that
was emailed to members of the committee
earlier today and there are paper copies
available for each of you as well so
we'll pick up the information in that
report as we consider each application
so we'll move on now to item six which
is the applications for permission to
develop uh just to explain to anybody
here in the room or watching for we've
got two applications we'll consider them
in the order that they are on the agenda
and for each of these items we'll start
with an introduction from one of the
planning team
we then have uh speakers for and against
applications so we'll hear from those
speakers against first and then four
each of the speakers will get three
minutes to uh to address us when refer
from those speakers we'll then start the
debate amongst members of the committee
and I will introduce those members uh by
name once they wish to contribute the
end of the discussion we will then uh
take a vote on whether to approve or or
reject the application
um so we're moving then to the first
application can I just interrupt sorry
yeah very briefly did I understand some
of the counselor that you uh you've you
were going to recuse yourself from
dealing with this matter
yes that's correct because it's
completely you have to leave the room
yeah no I will leave her in that's what
we're going to do as soon as it starts
yeah so we're about to start that one
right okay yeah
no problem yeah thank you cancer Menace
so yeah we'll consider the uh
application 106 507
um which is uh described as liberal
Democrat headquarters but it's the it's
the land at 43a Park Road in Temple
um and we'll start with an introduction
from uh Mr day please thank you
yeah thank you chair
um I'll just put the site plan on the
screen
[Music]
I have no idea
presenting the Powerpoints go back into
PowerPoint
going I'm just going to PowerPoint
slideshow but yeah
thank you
I'll just close this just yeah
I can't get the curse there
just out of this chance
I'll just be a short delay whilst we can
get the presentation up on the screen
behind us
foreign
[Music]
okay yeah we can just put the um
[Music]
the site plan on here okay yeah so the
application relates to the site of the
former liberal Democrat headquarters
situated to the north of Park Road in
timpley
the site is currently occupied by a
single story building and surrounding
hard standing with the plot being on a
significantly lower level than Park Road
the site is bound by two-story
Residential Properties to the Northeast
and Southeast
and a three-story apartment block to the
northwest
on the opposite side of Park Road there
is an apartment block and a row of
commercial properties with some
apartments above
the mature trees on the Park Road
boundary of the site are protected by
tree preservation order
and the site is located approximately 80
meters to the northeast of the templey
tram stop
the application seeks full planning
permission
clear the site
and in fact seven two and a half story
four bedroom dwellings
that's three pairs of so many Touched
houses and a single detached dwelling as
you can see on on the site plan there um
the single detached drying at the
Eastern end of the site
together with Associated hard and soft
Landscaping including parking so as you
can see the parking provision is at the
rear
um well the boundary with the properties
on Kensington Grove at the Northeast
boundary of the site
um the dwellings would face towards the
Northeast boundary with their rear
Gardens adjacent to the Southwest
Park Road boundary
the current ramped vehicle access would
be retained on the western side of the
site
with a separate stepped pedestrian
access provided at the Eastern end of
the site
the application is reported to committee
because six or more letters of objection
have been received
contrary to the office of recommendation
of approval
the key issues for consideration are the
principal of residential developments
together with the proposal's design
residential immunity and Highway impacts
just going through the the rest of the
slide obviously you can see the um
front elevation there which is when we
do when we're talking about the front
elevation that's actually the elevation
facing the properties on Kensington
Grove facing into the site on the
western elevation there and that's the
the rear elevation but the elevation
actually faces part Road in in this case
um
and the elevation at the Eastern end of
the site
same elevations in relation to the
detached dwelling
and layout plans
and there's some sections across the
site there
um
so the top section is looking from the
direction of the properties on
Kensington Grove
and you can see
um you can just see the the apartment
building
to the rest of the site
um
the proposed houses and and the houses
on
park close at the the East End of the
site
um and then obviously the section below
that is the section as viewed from Park
Road
um so you can see that the houses are
set below the level of the road
um
with the road obviously sloping up from
west to east
and a section across the site
um
from the front of from the Park Road
Frontage on the
um right hand side of the screen
um sloping down to the rear of the site
uh Landscaping plan again showing the
protected trees along the Park Road
Frontage to be retained
um and further planting
along the
western side boundary in particular and
along the and within the parking area
at the rear well the Northeast boundary
of the site
um the the two um
red circles show that the two trees that
are being taken out on the on the
western boundary
uh CGI image of the front
um as in the
the elevation facing
um the properties on Kensington Grove
um and then some site photographs that's
showing the apartment building
to the West with the access road
um going into the site
looking back at the access road to Park
Road
there you can see the existing building
on the site
um looking towards the western boundary
again the existing building with the
site Frontage and the trees on part Road
and looking towards the houses on
Kensington Grove
and again the trees on Art Road
and that's that's the housing park close
at the Eastern end of the site
that's
yeah
[Music]
um
so the first development is considered
to be acceptable in terms of the
principle of Housing Development on the
site and in terms of its design
appearance
its impact on residential immunity and
with regard to Highway matters
and all of the material planning
considerations
the proposal's design has been amended
to ensure it would result in an
acceptable visual impact in terms of its
positioning bulk massing and detailed
design
and as amended the proposed development
is considered to be in accordance with
the development plan and the application
is therefore recommended for approval
subject conditions thank you chair
thank you Mr day is Susan Berry with us
please hello come and have a seat at um
just opposite opposite me and if you
just um just bring yourself close to the
microphone
and then we'll be able to pick up what
you say and then if you just press that
button the red light should come on on
the microphone yeah and you'll have
three minutes and if you run up to three
minutes I'll just ask you to conclude
your remarks okay so whenever you're
ready thank you okay
so I believe that the recent planning
application should be refused on the
basis the proposed buildings are not of
a design that's in keeping with the
scale or appearance of the area the
issue of scale is particularly
impertinent given the proposal is to
extensively develop a relatively small
plot which will adversely affect my
property and those of other neighboring
properties due to their height and
proximity
the dwellings will be just a few meters
away from and directly facing the rear
aspect of homes along Kensington Grove
with each having a direct view into
bedrooms bathrooms kitchens lounges and
Gardens this would lead to a significant
reduction in our privacy and the direct
lighter sunlight preserved over many
years would be lost there's a wider
public concern around safety and
infrastructure Park Road struggles to
sustain the existing residential
population it's often inaccessible to
residents living in the surrounding area
due to prolonged congestion in both
directions towards Templar Village and
Trafford college and further pressure
will add to the significant traffic and
queuing which is over half a mile long
at peak times
increasing traffic in this area will
pose a risk to Children pedestrians
commuters walking along and Crossing
this busy road and add to the pollution
around the local homes and schools would
urge counselors to witness the
congestion along part Road for
themselves in terms of the proposed
buildings I would also urge councilors
to consider the site's access with its
sharp downward gradient into what is a
relatively small area of land and to see
how inaccessible it is especially for
emergency services Dustbin wagons and
delivery Vans these large Vehicles will
be required to drive over the pavement
area often during peak times and most
likely need to reverse back out of the
site via the incline onto part Road this
raises the important issue around safety
and the proposal which includes
dedicated parking for residents does not
consider the impacts of other multiple
Vehicles parked around the properties
which will prove problematic in terms of
having the available space to maneuver
so I would urge councilors to visit the
site to consider the complexities and
challenges around access and how the
planning application satisfies all
matters around safety although the plan
is to widen up access by following trees
either side of the exit onto part Road
logistically this will not eliminate the
aforementioned issue nor the risk the
commuters and parents walking with
children to Saint Hughes and Park Road
schools along the narrow path or to and
from Simply Metrolink
the visit will demonstrate how Vehicles
will be exiting the site via the Steep
incline and see the risk this poses to
pedestrians due to them having no clear
visibility of what is ahead or either
side of the drivers accident aside
emerge suddenly and without warning at
the top of the brow when crossing the
walkway stopping only to merge onto part
Road and obscuring the pavement in the
meantime until they're clear to move off
on the issue of environment I would urge
councilors to rethink the plan to remove
or reduce the any remaining trees
several mature trees have already been
fell to create space for the dwellings
and we should be considered a ecological
ecological impact of failing and
reducing mature trees that support
wildlife and contribute greatly to the
visual immunity of the area
any visual staging around the new
properties cannot compensate for or
mitigate for their loss as a final point
I would like to mention the previous
history of this land where prior to
timpley Tavern is being built there was
a small
pre-fabricated Hut that was used as a
mother and baby meeting place I realized
this is going back some years but when
it was decommissioned and the land
became available the council decided to
restrict developments at this site to
buildings only at single story level to
keep them in scale with the location and
size of the plot okay thank you if you
just want to conclude your remarks
please miss Barry is that okay so that
basically I was just going on to say
that though this will be a much better
and preferable alternative and I'm sure
there'd be support for any such plans
going forward thank you very much if you
just want to return to your seat thank
you for coming this evening
and it's Mr Shepard with us please yeah
yeah Mr Shepard if you just want to come
and have a a seat there just make sure
you're close to the microphone and just
make sure the microphone is on
yeah and you'll have three minutes thank
you
good evening thank you chair for
allowing me to address committee this
evening my name is Richard Shepard and
I'm a director of Nexus planning I speak
on behalf of my clients Landmark
property group in respect to the
proposal in front of you this evening
Landmark property group is based in
South Manchester and is an award-winning
residential developer of high quality
housing schemes many of which can be
found in the surrounding neighborhood
we welcome the officer recommendation to
approve the planning application
confirming that the scheme is policy
compliant and represents a sustainable
development on a key Brownfield site
we've worked proactively with your
officers over a number of months to
ensure that the scheme presented to you
today provides for a development which
responds to its surroundings
the site's constraints and is of an
exceptionally high quality design
in particular and taking careful
consideration of the consultation
responses received and comments made by
your planning officers
the scheme has been redesigned and
reduced in terms of the proposed number
of dwellings from eight to seven
the reduction in dwellings means that
the proposed properties are set far
enough away from neighboring boundaries
to ensure that there would be no
material impact on residential immunity
you will note from the committee report
that your officers have confirmed that
the sighting of the dwellings is
consistent with your policy requirements
the site is accessible on foot and Via a
range of public modes of Transport
particularly given its short walking
distance to Temporary tram stop and it
is also within walking distance of a
number of areas of open Green Space
including Newton Park and Sunderland
Brook which will benefit future
residents of the scheme
the Highway's evidence has been accepted
by the council's highways officer and it
not only demonstrates that the scheme
can be appropriately accommodated on the
site without adversely impacting on the
surrounding highways Network
but that also the internal Arrangement
and infrastructure allows safe movement
for pedestrians cars and Servicing
the residential use of the site will
result in fewer move vehicular movements
than the previous commercial sorry the
previous use of the site
the application is supported by a
sunlight and daylight assessment which
considers the proposed impact on the
existing neighboring properties and
Gardens and on the proposed new
dwellings and their Gardens also
the assessment demonstrates that the
development will not have a noticeable
effect on the daylight and sunlight
availability in any of the neighboring
Properties or their immunity space
overall the scheme represents a positive
investment on a key Brownfield site
which has been designed to ensure that
it is sympathetic to its surroundings
whilst creating a high quality
development which significantly improves
the Aesthetics of the application site
and provides much needed family housing
in Trafford thank you for your time
today and we hope you will support this
much needed Redevelopment scheme thank
you thank you Mr Shepard if you'd just
like to return to your seat at the back
of the room
um
so there were quite a few issues there
mentioned by by um
well by both speakers and I think
they're mainly addressed in the report
that we have
um
I wonder
Mr Dave you could
um give us any advice Miss Berry talked
about the former use of the site and an
understanding that development will be
restricted in the future to single story
buildings and just wonder if you could
uh tell us where there's any information
about that
yeah we don't have any information
um
in relation but in terms of what that
relates
to I mean obviously
the the site the development has to be
assessed in relation to current national
and local planning policies
um
um and there is no policy that would
specifically restrict the height of
development
um on the site and obviously
we've got to look at it in the context
that not only we got
two-story residential dwellings at the
rear
um but also a three-story apartment
block
adjacent to the site to the West So
within that context we feel that this
scale of development
um is appropriate
thank you Mr day and uh Mr Everson I
wonder if you could help us out with the
uh accessibility for larger vehicles and
the visibility which
both of our speakers mentioned I know I
know the local highways Authority have
no objection but I wonder if you could
sort of advise us on on how that
um response was arrived at and what sort
of assessment of accessibility and
visibility was was carried out thank you
yeah in terms of the accessibility by
the larger vehicles
um whilst the applicant has provided the
necessary tracking to demonstrate they
can get into the site and get out in a
forward gear we equally have the um
undertook the modeling exercise as well
in-house to make sure that what they
were doing and what they were sharing
because it is it is quite constrained so
we did check that out so we can confirm
that we did actually not just look what
they'd actually done but we'd actually
physically done it to Sales and so we
were quite satisfied that that could
actually work
um in terms of visibility space there is
some restrictions in terms of the
visibility display but they do provide
sufficient with uh visibility in terms
of vehicle access
um especially when you consider which is
already which has been mentioned the
existing the extant use
in that it's a car park and therefore in
terms of the numbers of traffic
um
it won't be significantly greater with
the proposal which we've got
and and that really goes along with Park
Road we accept that Park Road is
congested
um but seven new dwellings won't make a
significant impact on that Network and
therefore we couldn't demonstrate that
it was unacceptable in Highway terms in
that the capacity of that Network
wouldn't greatly increase on the back of
the seven dwellings and that's why we
came to the conclusion we did
thank you very much Mr Jefferson uh any
members looking to speak on this item
please counselor bunting
thank you chairman
um
I'm happy with the recommendation from
the planning officers uh and I'm more
than happy to propose that we accept uh
that recommendation
um in terms of the arguments that were
made uh if I could go through uh think
of the main main points in terms of the
design uh yes and it was uh described I
think as an outstanding design I
wouldn't go that far
um it's an acceptable design certainly
it's not a it's uh it's maybe not to my
taste but I think it is it is an
acceptable Zone and I've seen a great
deal worse that have come through this
committee so in terms of the design and
the fitting in to the uh into the area I
think that will be I think that will be
whilst I accept that the residents are
may be concerned and they're used to a
small low building behind their house
um both in terms of the building that's
out and the building that was there
before that and a change will obviously
cause some concern I I think given the
fact that it's a lower a a lower level
site and the height of the building
surrounding it I think it won't cause
any uh circumstance it won't cause any
undue issues and I think it once it's
been there for a while thing people will
fairly rapidly get used to the fact that
it's owned it's not going to be anything
uh outlandish in terms of this site and
I say I think the look and the of the
design and it from both the rear and
from the front are going to be are going
to be acceptable in terms of the traffic
which was also one of the issues as the
Harry's officer has already pointed out
this is not going to occur a significant
impact upon Park Road yes I'm sure we've
all driven up and down part mode on
various occasions and we're all well
aware of the traffic issues that uh that
that are there and I I I genuinely don't
feel that this is going to make a
significant impact if anything on uh the
busier periods when the club might have
been uh operating I think it'll be a
reduction uh in traffic on on those key
on those key those key times uh because
you'll have one or two vehicles coming
in per house rather than an entire Club
full of people trying to arrive and
taxis arriving and all the rest of it as
well as very late night leaving where
you know door slamming and all the rest
of it that'll probably be reduced and so
the noise impact from the traffic to the
neighbors if anything will be an
improvement
in terms of the access yes I accept it's
not ideal uh you know I visited the site
so I exited the site as it is at the
moment and I accept that uh the Harry's
officer has said that that will be fine
in terms of larger Vehicles also but
then again larger Vehicles will be
exiting as we stand at the moment drain
Vehicles you know uh commercial waste
what have you so I can't see that that's
going to be a significant uh a
significant issue either in terms of the
daylight again as the report makes it
clear uh distances and what have you are
acceptable and therefore I I genuinely
can't see that that is going to be a
significant problem either so chairman
in the absence of any compelling reason
to refuse uh I will as I said previously
I'll be proposing that we accept
um this could have been a great deal
worse it could have been a block of
Flats on this house so in on this site
so I am quite relieved in some ways that
we've got a an acceptable uh and
acceptable use for this land and with
that I'll look forward to seeing what my
colleagues have to say thank you
thank you Council the bunting councilor
Thomas thank you Joe
um again despite trying to find
planning reasons to to rail against it
um I can't uh the the to me it's not an
outstanding uh application but it meets
the criteria I'm disappointed the lffa
hasn't submitted a report we're just
being told that they accept it
um
it would be good to see that and and any
additional info report that we were told
in the report we would be getting the
report it's just uh we're just told in a
paragraph that uh that there's no
objection and as long as it's a carried
out in uh approved any strategy uh as a
report of condition 22 well there again
that isn't the reason I just for lunch
about that point the other point I would
lie to me and again we start planning
reason but I would like to stress as I
tend to do on these things if you are in
a wheelchair there is no access
there is plenty of scope to put a ramp
by The Pedestrian access if you wanted
to visit people in this house all right
to live in this house and go out in your
in your wheelchair where the motorized
or otherwise the access road is a single
track
which is dangerous I just wish wish that
people would consider
when when these plans together
accessibility I know it's not a planet
issue but it's a point no one's raised
and I will keep raising until we we go
somewhere with these Developers
the other thing with the single track is
if one vehicle is coming out on one
perhaps a lorry coming in it is going to
cause major problems on Power Road but
part road is already
full of major problems and again I agree
though whilst it will increase traffic
at certain times it won't make a huge uh
impact on on what is already uh a poor
road so I'm quite happy to Second it
because there's no reasons to not agree
with the officer's recommendation on a
planning thing I just like to just get
on record the thought
uh Behind these these developments thank
you chair
thank you Council Thomas any other
members I can speak counselor Welton
thank you I just wanted to uh
your attention to one particular aspect
which is the exit onto Park Road and
really in these this day and age we
should be expecting um a continuous
footway along there I'd thought which
would help with the um
uh you know with prioritizing
pedestrians using that that footway
it's quite hard to see from from the
from the plans what is exactly
what what is exactly there it looks like
a kind of a brick driveway
um
and uh you know it's the kind of thing
that I I don't know if we can put that
kind of thing in in the conditions for
for such a development
okay continuous Footwear as in as in you
know basically it's a it's a pavement
that people have to drive over rather
than it being a driveway that people
drive in and pedestrians are kind of
like considered to have to you know
you're talking about where the pavement
of part Road crosses this crosses the
site right okay thank you we can we can
we can clarify that
okay
yeah Mr everson's just gonna just kind
of buzz on that cancel the button in
terms of The Proposal it it is to retain
or to prioritize The Pedestrian as
opposed to the motorist
um and
in terms of a low level of traffic in
terms of an access going into a
effectively a private development it's
probably better to have it whereby the
pedestrians got the priority and the
motor is coming out whereas if it was
done with the curbs you would end up
having the tactile paving and it
restricts and causes issues with in
terms of pedestrians movement so when
you do have a curb access in the way you
just described it it does impede
pedestrians moving up and down the
Footwear freely so it is generally
thought and and perceived I think I'm
asking for the for the opposite of what
you're what you're saying so is it going
to be level it's going to be level it's
going to be as it is now yeah so that
the pedestrians effectively get the the
benefit of the priority there is for the
pedestrians and they haven't got to go
up and down curbs right that's good yeah
that's what I was trying it's not a
kid's entrance I am apologies I thought
it was the other way sorry yeah that's
that's what I yeah we would hope it
would be yeah I certainly understand
what the residents you know concerns
about about traffic on on Park Road I
really feel that that is unfortunately
it's not an issue for this
um uh for for this is committee it's
that's a political issue that needs to
be dealt with by by local councilors
um and and I think residents should
definitely
speak to them about you know
what needs to be done about what can be
done with Park Road and in particular
increasing provision for active travel
in that area
um but I don't think it you know it can
hold up this I tend to agree with um my
my colleagues and we do have to bear in
mind that if we don't build in in
Brownfield sites like this then we then
then the pressure is much more on the
green belt green belt is you know areas
of uh are less connected they're less
sustainable you know um hopefully people
who move here they will their children
will go to the local schools and they
won't have to drive to the local schools
because they're so close to the local
schools and that means some people
you know who do get into the local
schools at the moment from further away
they won't be able to get into those
local schools so there will be fewer
people driving there you know these are
swings and roundabouts with these things
it looks like an okay
um design and development and I can't
see also can't see any planning reasons
to reject it so I'll be supporting in
favor thank you
thank you councilor Welton Miss Mary I
know you've got your hand up but I'm
afraid we can't enter into further
debate with the speakers so we we have a
a limited time for speakers to speak to
us and and you've had that time in Mr
Shepard house so it's it's now just a
discussion amongst the committee I'm
afraid uh
didn't do something
no I'm afraid we can't enter into
discussion with you now at this point
we've had the advice from from offices
on that point as well
um councilor Proctor were you looking to
speak yes thank you
um yeah I'm going to be pretty much
agreeing with what's uh been said
already by the members
um there was quite a lot of objections
15 and some of those were valid applying
objections some were uh ones that we
can't take into account but in terms of
the ones that are valid I think the
report has addressed that in terms of
the you know the visual impact
the over development the privacy of you
Etc I think they've they've been
addressed in the report so as others
said there's no real planning reasons to
reject this as other people have said my
one concern was with the vehicle access
um and the the potential of you know
accidents happening on part work is
actually a busy road but I think that's
been addressed already by the uh traffic
officer so
um you know there was not a lot of
information about that and report but I
think that's reassured me now that uh
what we've been told this evening
um do the fact thing that was mentioned
in terms of parking which always is in
schemes but um you know there's
sufficient parking spaces and as the
report says it's very close to the tram
station so I think that that is is
something that's
um not really an issue
um just want to pick up what councilor
Thomas was saying I agree 100 what a lot
about the accessibility you know we
don't look at the is enough in these
sort of schemes nothing we can do about
it at this stage but I think it's
something that we do need to bear in
mind so I will be voting in favor of
this application thank you
thank you councilor Proctor any other
members looking to speak councilor
Hassan
all right thank you chair
it looks me very uh very positive
investment in that area and we are
really desperately and dire need of more
uh
housing development in Trafford and all
the Visas have already cleared about the
accessibility and visibility and the
applicant represented to have just clear
about the distance about the existing
dwellings and the housing who are going
to build so in my point of view it is
absolutely a
a positive addition in that area and
just my colleague has mentioned
uh Park Road has a lot of connection
connectivity which is easy on the uh
washway buses and the schools
connections and of course the motor
sorry the Trump stations it's on a
walking distance so I don't think it's
any problem and I will be supporting
this application and I recommend the
officer's recommendation thank you
thank you for Hassan any other members
looking to speak
no I mean for my part I'll maybe just
pick up a few things that haven't been
said if I may I know it was very raised
concerns around the the separation uh
distances to the houses on Kensington
Grove but I I think that's addressed in
the report and the the separation
distances are all in accordance with the
with the guidelines
um so I'm satisfied that the the
distances and the the impact on uh
residential amenities been been fully
considered
um
the silly access ramp so I I mean my own
view is it it's it's adequately
addressed in the in the report so
um uh paragraph uh 56 and onwards which
I know has been
uh has been corrected in the additional
information report but my understanding
is that that was considered and it was
discounted because of the change in
level it wouldn't be possible to
construct a a pedestrian access ramp
that complied with building regulations
and I also suspect that would mean
um felling more of the trees on that
boundary which are protected by a tree
preservation order so it is a balancing
act but I do think that has been that
has been considered
um I mean it may be that the agent
uh Mr Shepard couldn't know the concerns
around the
shared access for for vehicles and
pedestrians uh down the ramp and and I
think there probably doesn't need to be
some consideration there to make sure
whether that's lighting or warning signs
just to make sure that drivers are aware
that that is pedestrian access as well I
think that would be something to
consider
um
I think that came to the Welton I had a
slight concern around the visibility
um and priority for pedestrians so it's
good to hear that that continuous
pavement will be maintained I think that
will just be a prompt for drivers to
make sure that they do give way to
pedestrians that are passing
apologies uh finally I also like the
Landscaping I think Landscaping is good
I know there's a concern about trees
being failed but there is a specific
condition for 21 new trees to be planted
so I think I think that's a net gain
um yeah and everything else I think
other members have covered so I'm quite
positive about the application I think
the design is good it's a Brownfield
site I think the site can accommodate
the um seven houses
um so yeah I'll be also voting in favor
of the of the application uh councilor
Winston
yeah I mean I
um
I also probably voting in favor of this
we want to pick up on some of the points
made by uh other members around
accessibility and whether you can build
uh a ramp in line with building
regulations on this site and it's really
a message to the developer you can you
just can go to go to Stratford Metro and
you'll see exactly the same layout there
and if if they will to build the Rampage
there then it's um then it can be built
and against the point we've made to
officers many times is to get into the
conversation on these things very early
on with developers and then things will
change thank you chair
thank you councilwin Stanley any other
members looking to speak
okay we've heard from a lot of members
so uh it's been proposed and secondly
that we accept the officer's
recommendation to uh approve plan and
permission so we will uh vote on that so
all all those members in favor of uh
approving the application please in
accordance with office of recommendation
and that is uh unanimous
thank you everybody
um so that's the end of the item to
cancel this and I think you're leaving
us now thank you and we'll just get
counselor Menace back in
foreign
we'll move on to the second application
on the agenda which is uh application
number 108 407 8 Hampton Avenue in
Stratford and we will start with an
introduction from Miss Milner thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
the application for members relates to
eight Hampton Avenue a two-story
semi-touch property in Stratford
the planning history background are
important for understanding the context
of the current proposal
in October 2017 Planning Commission was
granted for the erection
of a single story part two story part
single story part two story side
extension and single story rear
extension
then in July 2019 planning permission
was granted for the erection of a
two-story side extension and a single
Story Road Extension this followed the
2017 permission but extended out further
to the rear
and she'll be able to see
um it was this section
approved here the fabric send it out
following the granting of planning
permission work commenced on site in
addition to the approved works the
original roof was extended from a hip to
a gable roof with a box or rear box
Dormer
the council received a complaint
regarding this and this was investigated
by the planning compliance team
it was apparent that development as
constructed on site did not Accord with
the approved plans in addition to the
changes to the roof and the addition of
a dormer the single story extension to
the rear also extended out to a greater
depth foreign
of the development Arts site currently
with the Box Dormer
um and then this is to photograph to the
bottom just shows you the house on the
left as it was prior to Construction
a new planning application was then
submitted in July 2020 to retain the
development as built on site this
application was subsequently refused in
November 2020 on design grounds
specifically referencing the roofscape
of the dwelling which was considered to
appear in Congress within the
surroundings
following the refusal applying
commission an appeal was submitted to
the Planning inspectorate by the
applicant this was dismissed by the by
the inspector who agreed with the reason
for refusal
as the development on site did not
occurred with the approved planning
application and permission to retain the
development as built was found to be
unacceptable by both the council and the
planning inspectorer an enforcement
notice was served in April 2022 as
detailed within paragraph 5 of your
committee for report the enforcement
notice provided two possible courses of
action either remove the extensions to
the side in rear
or build the proposal in accordance with
um the 2019 planning permission
in response to the notice the applicant
and their agent sought to address the
specific areas of concern with the
previous refusal and the as built
development on site and submitted the
current application which is now before
members
the application seeks to overcome the
harm caused by the existing Enterprise
extension and find an alternative
solution to the requirements of the
enforcement notice
the council cannot design alternative
solutions for property owners but the
applicant is entitled to
test an alternative design for either
submission of a fair Pro application
which is an appropriate Court which is
an appropriate and acceptable course of
action and that is the case before
members this evening
the current application seeks to attain
the single story rear extension and the
massing of the two story side extension
but alter the roof structure over the
main house and side extension and reduce
the scale of the rear Dormer
for the neighbor notification process
objections have been received from Seven
addresses on Hampton Avenue citing
reasons of design amenity parking land
ownership and procedural questions as
detailed within your report report
officers do appreciate that the
development timeline on this property
from the original application to the
current date is approximately five years
which is understandably caused distress
to local residents however the current
application seeks to regularize some of
the works on site and address the
concerns of the previous refusal
whilst the proposed filament would be
highly visible within the street saying
and surrounding areas it's considered on
balance to present a satisfactory design
solution
and given the relationship to
neighboring properties not resulting in
a harmful impact on amenity
it is also considered there is adequate
parking on site and as such offices are
recommending the proposal for approval
should members support the
recommendation for approval the existing
enforcement notice will better be varied
to include the current proposed scheme
and that will then become an option on
the enforcement notice and a suitable
time scale for completing those Works
will be agreed with the applicant
if members are minded to refuse the
scheme the enforcement notice as issued
stands and it would be for the applicant
to either undertake the works as
detailed within the enforcement notice
or submit an appeal on this scheme thank
you chair
thank you very much Miss Miller um we
have a speaker listed against this is
sand two with us please come and have a
seat uh opposite me thank you
and if you just make sure you're close
to the microphone just so we can pick up
from what you say just press the button
yeah can you hear me now yeah yeah um
you'll have um three minutes to speak to
us and if you
um run up to time I'll just ask you to
wrap up thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you for allowing me to
speak on behalf of number 10 Hampton
Avenue who live right next door uh to
the development and evening or the uh
esteem members good to see you again
um my name is sun and uh as you know
this is a retrospective planning
application
um you know in the wake of the planning
of review show and it has gone to appeal
which has been dismissed and this is the
second attempt uh to justify this
development uh many of you I'm sure that
would have already gone to through SI
visits or have readily many reports and
statements put up by the many neighbors
in the vicinity of the development which
address many planning related ponds in
including the scale or the massing of
the development which is oversized
but I would like to use this option is
here to address a more personal note
and I'm going to show to the committee
members some photos of the development
that has been done previously sorry Mr I
don't think we can look at photos that
you that you brought with us so the only
information that we should consistent
yeah okay that's fine may I ask
the members to uh probably address the
um the youth details on the proposed
plan do you think that's possible the um
on the elevation plan okay yes that's
the one
is it possible to zoom in
um to the to the eve
that's right yeah so if you can see that
um a 150 millimeters was allowed
um uh for the eve the overhang and also
the guttering now a standard
gutter diameter a half round guttering
is 115 millimeters
this is simply not sustainable as a bill
imagine that when it rings on a typical
day then the next door will be flooded
with rain water
I would argue that the development is
simply not sustainable at all and the
drawing is easy for us to to put up some
drawings to tuck everything behind the
boundary line but the fact of the matter
is that it shows the attitude the
applicant is trying to put towards the
development
and may I also you know draw your
attention to this sewage pipe that has
already been built
in protest of number 10 on number 10's
land which is leaking to this day and
hopefully it does summarize the attitude
of the applicants towards the
development now every day the next store
neighbors suffer as a result of this I
would love to show you some photos the
report was put in as part of the thing
uh the the response and all in all I
just would like to invite uh the
Community member to vote this down it's
an oversized project
and and to stop the suffering once and
for all thank you
thank you very much for coming to us
Miss Miller I wonder if you could um
if you could say anything about those
two points that were just uh raised
about the overhang of the eaves and then
the um the waste pipe on number 10 if we
know anything about those thank you so
we um through the enforcement
proceedings we were made aware that the
development did encroach
um according to number 10 onto their
property
um
number eight in number 10
um commissioned a independent surveyor
um to kind of draw the the true the true
boundary line and this information was
submitted to us and in response to that
um the applicant number eight got their
architect to to kind of redesign their
drainage system to pull it in off the
boundary so that no part of the
development as proposed would encroach
over the boundary line
um
we can we have to take that evidence
we've made
reasonable inquiries on that matter and
that is what we are
um
you know to do through the planning
system if that is disputed
um by the application Sorry by number 10
their recourses through civil action
uh thank you Mr Miller any members
looking to speak uh councilor Thomas
um
massing
is a huge problem here we we've not
redressed anything other than slight
variation to the roofline and uh
potentially the Dormer part of the roof
um paragraph four in the background in
the observations uh says that he's noted
the instructor's report does not refer
to the side red extension that's
contributing for the reasons for refusal
and solely relates to the roof design
including the Dormer and therefore
general form of massing to the side area
sanctions has been accepted by the
inspector
I read their inspector's report today on
application 101 432 and that's just not
the case
not the case in any way shape or form
paragraph 11 of the inspector report
says uh
consequently taken into all over above
into consideration I conclude that this
development harms a character and
appearance of the house dwelling and the
surrounding area the character
in conflict with policy L7 and spd4
which we seeks amongst other things to
ensure developments
are appropriate in their content and
enhance the street scene or character of
the area he would also be contrary to
the requirements of traffic councils
spd4
which states extension should reflect
the character scale and form of the
original dwelling particularly in
relation to roof style
and being proportionate in size which
says obviously is not if you've been to
visit the site moreover there's a
conflict with the national planning
Province policy framework a national
design guide which requires amongst
other matters for development to be
sympathetic to local character and add
to the overall quality of the area it's
not just solely about the roof it goes
on earlier earlier in the thing is the
massing is in there and the massing was
the reason for reviews or part of the
reason for use refusal 101 432 and that
has not been redressed in any way shape
or form so I would like to propose that
we reject the officer's recommendation
and refuse this application thank you
thank you Council Thomas counselor
bunting
thank you chairman
um I'm going to take the contrary
opinion if I may
um if we look at page 32 uh in the
report we obviously have the three sets
of of designs uh top design obviously
still
it's an approved application so
obviously as the officer said if I've
make sure I've got this right if the
applicant was refused this evening they
could amend the building to reflect the
top design that has already been
approved and therefore they could go
ahead so the base point that we're
discussing here and now is not the
building as it was originally or the
building as it is now it's the building
as it as it was originally you could do
that you could go immediately go to the
approved design and take that or you
could go for the proposed design should
we choose to accept it this evening I
accept absolutely that the current
situation as it stands is completely
unacceptable it in in terms of it just
looks absolutely horrific it is entirely
detrimental to the street scene as it
stands I am not surprised in the least
that the neighbors are upset about the
way it looks at the moment it's a very
nice Road it must have never been to
this road before it's very pleasant uh I
most likely Community aspect of the road
as it stands here the small community
garden a little Library across the road
Hobson area the way the residents like
to look after it and to take and take
pride in the area they live and that's
that's a good thing
in terms of the top and the bottom
design a that which is approved already
and that which is proposed again this is
always a degree of subjectivity
surrounding this but especially the
front aspect uh and to a degree the rear
uh I think the proposal is actually
better than the except than the approved
so why would if it were me living there
I would rather rather than revert to the
original application I would hope that
if we passed it this evening you could
still do either he could still go for
the approved or the proposed but I would
personally if I were living in this area
prefer the proposed than the approved
but then I I think it sits better within
the environment I think the design is
superior uh especially at the front uh
the rear maybe is with the scaled down
Dormer with the amendment to the to the
windows
um uh and on the rear extension I think
that is okay it's not maybe as
beneficial as front of the front is
probably the main thing that they're
concerned about
so for me we have that point if this was
a case of well refuse it and it all goes
back to the way that it was originally
that might be something to be looking to
do but that isn't the case that that
ship has sailed so we have a choice
between the approved number of proposed
with the option that you could choose to
take everything down regardless because
I'd imagine that's probably highly
unlikely so on those grounds of guns
that I think the proposed is a better
design that would sit in to this area uh
in a superior way to the approved design
I am minded to agree with the officers
and to that aim chairman I will propose
just that that we accept the design as
it is it's
certainly is better than the approved
it's certainly a whole hell of a lot
better than that which is there and that
would I think the proposed design
resolved many of the concerns that the
residents have quite rightly raised
following the building of the
unfortunate mess that is there thank you
chairman
thank you Council bunting councilor
Welton
thank you I was just going to point out
that the photographs that were being
referred to are actually I think
probably present in the objection from
number 10 hackton Avenue if people want
to have a look at those so they are
available to us
um I am finding that this this is really
really tricky so I'm I'm hedging my bets
at the moment and I will speak later um
should I feel moved to thank you
foreign
Stanley
thank you chair yes this is really
really tricky I have great sympathy with
the the residents on the road I really
do
um
and if we could why if I was able to
wind this back to the approval of the
first design I don't think
I would I wouldn't have approved the
original design I would not have done
that however
to go back to counselor bunting's point
if we turn the design down
um which is in front of us tonight then
the applicant can revert to the original
design and I suspect that's what they
will probably do and if you compare the
original design to the zombies in front
of us now the design which is in front
of us now in my view is a better design
um and given the fact that we cannot
revoke the plan of permission for the
original design
I think I'm inclined to vote for what's
in front of me now I don't like it I
don't like the position that you're in
but I'm afraid I think that's the
position we find ourselves in thank you
chair
thank you councilman Sunday Council
Thomas did you want to say something
further thank you chair I'm going to
point out that that is not the case at
all we've not got the choice of saying
yes to this or reverting to the original
design there was an enforcement notice
in place to remove the past Single part
two-story side extension single story
rear extension rear dormant extension
return the property is conditioned
before the breach took place
foreign
just to clarify it's either remove it
all
built the approved scheme that's exactly
right no it's remove it all or a build
the approved scheme considering that the
um the resident so it's remove it all or
or this no no or what's in front of us
tonight it would move it all or build
the approval
so on the proof on the proposed
so it's either take off think off yeah
build what's on the top of your screen
or build what is proposed tonight so
it's not top or bottom it's top bottom
or remove it
under the enforcement Aries yes
through the chair please Council minutes
through the chair please okay
um Council Thomas just just stop that
let's
um let's go to Miss Miller just just to
advise clearly on what the the options
are under the enforcement notice so as
it stands the enforcement enforcement
notice says either remove everything
yeah or alter the scheme
to their Pro scheme from 2019 which is
the one at the top if this is approved
tonight this becomes the third option
so there's three options not too
currently there's two but there would be
three if you would yes time was approved
yeah tonight's reviews there's two
options remove or revert yeah I'm
considering you've already got our
approved plans these ignored
he's gone past the approved approved
plans I'm very concerned that it is a
proposed or the approved plans will be
ignored again okay so that's just a
point in an opinion okay Council yeah so
again I reaffirmed that I I I'm against
this okay I I don't so I don't think we
can uh I don't think we should Express
opinions on on the motivations of the
applicant I know this is a retrospective
application but he's entitled to make an
application
um and and we consider it on the
planning merits that are before us
um
that is
just for clarity so I'm I know where
we're up to in terms of the debate
through YouTube MMS was counselor when
Stanley makes uh seconding the proposal
or not if you would if I may I started
to be chairman so we're Stanley no no
okay
um
Council Bluffton I come to you and come
to you in a moment if I may
um
Miss Miller sorry could you also
um advise on the inspectors report from
an appeal so councilor Thomas did refer
to uh I think I think the summer in the
report not not being accurate in his
view I don't know if we've got the
report available
Rebecca has it in front of her
I think
in terms of the refusal
I think with the approved scheme we take
that as the Baseline so even though oh
sorry it's here
sorry and even though
um
so the 2019 was the approved scheme
when they applied for the as built
scheme to be approved
we almost have to accept a certain level
of massing that we've already
um agreed to so the focus of the report
the focus of our concern was the massing
resulting from those proposed changes
so I think we've we've noted in the
report there are certain elements of
this scheme that we wouldn't necessarily
be supportive of now and I think you
know we were quite open about that in
the report but we're saying that you
know in 2017 we accepted a certain level
of massing in 2019 we accepted a greater
level of massing what we had issue with
in the 2020 scheme that tipped that
balance into refusal was that increased
massing to the roof and the Dormer and
not just the increased massing to the
roof but the change in Styles between a
hip roof and meeting a hip roof to a hip
to a Gable and it was the cumulative
impacts of those changes that we saw to
be unacceptable
thank you
we've got the inspectors report that
could we have a look at um paragraph 11
which I think was the part that
councilor Thomas
referred us to
maybe we just paused there so we can
have a read
chair if I if I may uh just briefly on
the report no just hold on please
um I'll just come to miss curly because
Miss Dakota is going to take us through
all the parts in the report and that
that may address um what your queer was
counselor Thomas so we'll just do that
first if we may
I will turn my microphone on sorry which
has got the elevation plans on it so
the inspector if if we start so the
inspector starts with what what the
character context is in in paragraph
seven
and then refers specifically to the
alterations to the roof of the property
so that that is
um
I read that as being the existing roof
so that is the hip to Gable as you see
on the
um left hand side of the roof on the
left hand drawing and the Dormer
extension which you see on across the
rear of the roof
um
this is the refused one yes yes in the
middle one unfortunately we can't show
but it'll probably be easier if if we
could show both but unfortunately I can
only show one document at a time
um
and then and describes that as an alien
Reef form and I think quite rightly and
we agree with that and then talks about
the setback of the side extension has
resulted in a smaller hit element to the
roof at a lower level and you can see
that on both drawings front and rear
um next to that hip to Gable extension
um over that over that side extension
which reasoned in Congress and harmful
addition and says the development has
unbalanced the uh pair of semis of which
it forms part
uh that it says in paragraph nine the
rear Dormer does not reflect the form of
the existing roof and reads as a top
heavy and overly dominant addition to
the dwelling uh due to its scale but
bulk and positioning then intrusive over
large bulky addition which is
significantly altered the roofscape of
the host property and semi-detached pear
he then talks about permitted
development
matters which is which is about the hip
to Gable
um and is a is a technical point
at no nowhere in that decision does the
inspector suggest that
the body of the side extension or the
rear extension is unacceptable it is all
in relation to the roof and and that is
why officers consider the fallback
position to be well partly what has been
approved which is
um which is what we see in the the at
the extensions to the
um rear Insider are they are slightly
different but not significantly so
um and the inspector's report which has
to be a primary material consideration
the consideration of this application as
well uh it has to carry great weight
don't
um raise any objection to the side and
rear extensions it is just the roof and
that is another reason why office is
consider the proposed scheme before you
this evening to be acceptable
just also to add into in relation to the
appeal
that the inspector would have seen the
delegated report written in response to
the refuse scheme and the delegated
report for that scheme focuses on the
roof it's the design assessment
um starts with saying you know the
proposed changes to the roof unbalance
the scheme that is where the harm arises
and that is the focus of the refusal so
the refusal as it's gone to the
inspector is focusing on those changes
to the roof and that is how the
inspector is assessing our reason for
refusal
thank you Miss Miller uh councilor
Welton
[Music]
in oh yes I know I always yes the the
drain the um uh the speaker was talking
about the drainage
um and how it was impacting the property
next door
um I don't know if can we have a comment
on that as to whether that is a a
planning consideration in terms of you
know
um the amenity of neighbors
um thank you
foreign
and drainage is dealt with through the
building regulations protocol so it
won't be for them to look at and
um any drain that directly over spills
into a neighboring property is dealt
with under a specific section of the
building regulation that specific
section escapes me right now but it is
it is dealt with through them and if
there is um encroachment
beyond what we are aware of it would be
civil action
thank you Council Proctor uh yeah thank
you chair um I'm tending to agree with
what council Thomas has said really in
terms of the reasons to reject the
officer's recommendation I I know we've
got a really sort of be very careful
with this we're not tainted by what's
happened in the history of their
application then we don't take that into
consideration what we need to do is look
at the plans we'll go in front of us
and I think it is it's going to be
dominant and it's going to it's going to
impact on the the residents of the
residence properties and I think it's
going to have an impact on the the
street scene as well and certainly I
think looking at the the location of the
properties certainly number 10 I think
it's going to impact quite significantly
and number 12 as well to some degree
um so you know looking just purely
looking this application on its own
Merit uh I would be moving to reject it
you know as councilor Thomas said that
one of the thing that was in the um the
report is in terms of the
um the highway decision parking I don't
think that's relevant whatsoever there's
no sort of real real issues there
um in terms of the numbers of parking
spaces Etc so but I think it does it
does have a a negative impact as you
know the seven objections have said
um from the the neighbors so I'll be
um thinking along those lines along with
councilor Thomas thank you
thank you cancer Proctor um do I
understand from that you were willing to
Second counselor Thomas's motion that we
refuse yes thank you
any other members looking to speak on
the item
counselor just with Sue Israel as far as
I as I said following the explanation
for Mrs Coley that the uh The Proposal
complies with and addresses all the
points made in terms of the refusal that
we looked at previously and in terms of
council Proctor's comment he says
impact on the street scene I can see
that it has that they refused has an
impact on the sweet scene but the
argument the proposal has a greater or
Worse impact on the street scene than
that which is already approved I would
argue it's a false argument we're not
talking about nothing there we're
talking about proposed versus approved
we can't wish away the approved uh
scheme and pretend that it doesn't exist
which is what I would argue was just
happening there it's approved versus
proposed not proposed versus nothing and
that's the point I'll just keep making
thank you chairman okay thank you guys
for bunting any other members looking to
speak Council a minute
I've waited a while because I thought I
don't I don't like it at all um I don't
I mean I mean I I know that we obviously
have to and the thing is we do need to
look at fullback is
approved
um and and uh the currently what's there
is is awful
um and what we're looking at is is the
proposed is the proposed
um I think it actually probably does
look a bit better the back of it's not
great I'm not I'm personally not a fan
of the flat roof thing
um but it is at the back of the property
and
um therefore you can't I can't say it's
a loss of of immunity
um I I think that
I guess it's the the proposed looks
better than the approved at the front of
the property is my take on it the back
of the property I personally don't like
it I don't I I mean whether the the
applicant will then do the proposed or
carry on whatever they're going to do we
don't know and it's not something that
we can we can do anything about
um and you know we'll just it will be if
we if it's approved if we approve the
proposed it's down to something outside
of planning so I think that what we are
here for is to decide whether the
proposed is is
um
acceptable even if we don't like it type
thing and I think I can't see a reason
to say
um no so I think I'm going to have to
second the proposal by by Dan here
um to to go to actually be was
environmental officer recommendation I
just don't see another way forward with
it
um I I get there clearly not not the
nicest of neighbors and you know but I
think we have to get somewhere with it
thank you
okay thank you councilman yeah I don't I
don't think we should speculate on on
the applicant or whatever the honest
neighbors that we don't have any
information on that and even even if we
did it wouldn't be irrelevant running
consideration
um
yeah
[Music]
you can't you can't wish away so we're
just going to hear from Miss Mill now
with some advice on the uh enforcement
action that we that we could take just
to clarify because if members were
minded to prove this we would then
formally vary the enforcement notice to
say put this as an option if you don't
comply with an enforcement notice unlike
planning permission it is a criminal
offense so there is you know once this
is on the um
on the enforcement notice it does have
greater power
thank you
that is useful any other members looking
to speak
I mean I
I I'm I'm comfortable with it you know I
I uh I would
um agree with councilor Bunting and
councilor Menace In in thinking that we
that we should approve this
um I won't repeat the exercise that um
councilor bunting said but the diagrams
on page 32 are are really useful very
illustrative I think and that the
differences between what's uh already
been approved and what's proposed uh and
not significant I think it's arguable
whether it's whether it's better than
what was approved but
um they're not significant differences
so if what was approved was an
acceptable form of of massing and
acceptable visual immunity acceptable
and Street Scene I can't see that the
difference is with the proposed scheme
uh make make it not so
um
well I suppose you're gonna think I'd
say is
we don't know the full history of what's
of what's happened here and but it
sounds like this has been going on for
some time and I do have sympathy with uh
with Mr Mr Mr Terry came to speak to us
about that and thinking about what is
going to resolve this
um I actually think approving the
proposed scheme will will help to bring
this to a conclusion
more quickly
um and in a sense the enforcement notice
and the action that's been taken has
been successful because
um the the applicant has come forward
with the scheme which officers are
recommending
um for approval and and I agree with
that so
I think it's it's a Temptation always
think enforcement action means you've
got to pull everything down but that is
obviously the last resort and it takes
some time to get there but but the
result here is that we have a scheme
which I think it I think is now
acceptable Miss Mill has just given us
some advice on what would happen if
um if the enforcement notice was varied
in that way and then still not uh still
not followed what what the options would
be
um so I'm I'm happy with what's proposed
I don't think the difference is um make
it unacceptable so I would
um the support the officer's
recommendation on this
any other members looking to speak or
against the Welton
thank you um yes I I think I after
having listened to the discussion uh I
think I I would agree with that um and
you're considering this going forward to
the you know if we did reject it going
forward to the um the you know the
planning inspector
um you know I wouldn't be confident that
this this wouldn't this wouldn't get
approved or our decision would wouldn't
get overturned
um which of course would prolong things
for everyone and I would you know I I
think possibly the resident the
neighbor's energy is better put into
um you know the civil action now to make
sure you know to to make sure that
they're actually you know and and and
also looking at the building regs to
make sure that everything is in in place
and as it should be
um but it may be that they've gone as
far as they can in the planning process
now
thank you councilor councilman
um I was always minded to uh support
this but I feel more reassured I haven't
spoke listened to miss Milner about the
enforcement action because I know that
it's immaterial how they've proceeded
before
um and having read the report I knew
there wasn't anything that we as a
planning committee could do about that
but I do feel really more reassured that
the enforcement and that if we did go
for the proposed one
it's more likely that they'll build what
they should build
so therefore I'm supporting it
thank you councilor I can uh councilor
Thomas yeah
um just just to add to uh my uh proposal
to fuse part of the reason it would be
along the lines of and out of the
officer's report from the appeal that
the development has been balanced a pair
of ceremy's which informs Parts even
take into account the extension to the
neighbor as a consequent the
contribution that the house dwelling
makes to the character appearance for
the area has been significantly eroded
that is the appeals officer's view so
whilst I appreciate that there's there
is
continuously uh unaccepted approved
proposal going forward there there is
Basis that this is
the wrong decision to approve this
proposed
uh
ply application
okay thank you Council Thomas so it has
been moved and seconded that we uh
refused the application against officer
recommendation
um before we before we vote on that we
do need to clarify the reasons for
refusal so you've mentioned something
there Council Thomas so perhaps I'll
turn to miss Cowley just to summarize
what we understand as the reasons for
refusal
I heard it from councilor Thomas it's
about the appearance and balancing this
the
um the Paris having attached properties
which would have a harmful impact on the
character of the area I didn't hear
anything about residential immunity
Council Thomas although you did mention
it in passing before are you simply just
moving it on the grounds of character uh
well it's visually means isn't it uh as
as upheld by the um Planet Spectrum
report that's in there as well so
massing and
as I just read out here
thank you
and information a a query of Mrs Cody
through you if I may
except I heard obviously what cast
honestly the unbalancing effect may I
ask in given the fact that they approved
design comes out to the uh basically
just the same as the proposed in terms
of unbalancing I.E extends the width of
one property in comparison to the other
and therefore the approved could
uh be deemed to unbalance it just as
much as the proposed and therefore
because we're talking about that is the
fallback rather than nothing how do we
stand in terms of that as a reason for
refusal given the fact that the
unbalancing aspect
and the mass of it effectively has
already been approved via the original
approval now I asked that question
through you chairman please I don't
think we've been an appeal
um but we need to take a reason to for
the vote so um and we'll need to proceed
with that
okay we will um Mr Taylor Sorry I know
you've got your hand up we can't engage
in sort of further a bit
um no I think I think we've had a debate
before the committee and and you have
spoken to us um we've received advice on
on several issues uh and I I think we're
gonna vote now on the on the motion to
refuse proposed by uh Council Thomas
second aback Angela Proctor and we've
got our
um proposed reasons for refusal so if I
could ask members to vote on that first
so all those in favor of refuse or if
you could raise your hands now please
okay and all those against refusal
okay
so that is uh not carried
yeah and it will now vote on the uh the
motion to approve uh councilor bunting
preparers then cancel a minute second as
well as in favor of approval if you
could indicate now please
okay and all those against approval
please okay
that is uh carried so permission is
approved for the application thank you
very much everybody
that brings us to the end of item six
which is the applications item number
seven is uh any urgent business and I
understand there is none so uh at that
point I will uh close the meeting and
thank everybody for attending thank you